Welcome to the Friday show, I have a few stories
I want to run through before we move on to
other things, including your questions.
We talked last week about the continued
possibility that Donald Trump will start his
own political party. We also saw a poll showing
that nearly two thirds of Republican voters
are, in theory, willing to leave the Republican
Party and follow Trump to a new party. Now,
of course, if Donald Trump started a new party
and forget about 64 percent, if Donald Trump,
Trump took 50 percent or 40 percent or even 30
percent of Republican voters to a new party,
it could spell absolute disaster for the American
right, splitting the vote and allowing the
Democratic Party to win a lot to take a phrase out
of Donald Trump's vocabulary. There's now another
new story, and this is being reported by Reuters.
There are dozens of former Republican officials
who view the Republican Party as unwilling to
stand up to Donald Trump. So this is an anti
Trump group of former Republican officials.
And what these individuals are saying is,
if the Republican Party won't stand up to Trump
and say, no, we reject Trump ism and we reject
Trump, they are in discussions to break away from
the Republican Party and start their own. And
this includes former officials in the Republican
administrations, Ronald Reagan, George H.W. Bush,
George W. Bush, as well as even disaffected
Trump aides and staffers and political employees.
This includes some Republican ambassadors. This
includes some Republican strategists and others.
And 120 of them had a zoom call, of course,
last Friday to have a conversation about this.
And the idea is they would say the Republican
Party has become the party of Trump.
We are getting back to principled conservatism,
as they call it. What that means is pretending to
care about the debt and deficit. Let's not mistake
that for anything else. But it doesn't matter
because, again, this could also be an absolute and
total disaster for the Republican Party. One of
the people involved is Evan McMullen. You might
remember he ran third party in 2016, former CIA
agent, I believe, and he is part of this movement
for a possible splinter party. I have to tell you
that this is fantastic news. Imagine if we
got. But these would be two gifts if Donald,
you've got the Republican Party and within it
you have people who want to stick with Trump
and people who want the Republican Party to
completely denounce and distance from Donald
Trump. You could have a situation where so-called
principled conservatives in the Republican Party
split off and start their own party to get away
from Trump. And at the same time, Donald Trump
starts his own party and takes the hyper pro Trump
people away as well. So you could end up with. The
Trump Party taking away from the Republican Party,
the principled conservative former Republicans who
are anti Trump splitting off from the Republican
Party, and then I guess what you'd have left in
the Republican Party are just generally people
not paying much attention or who don't don't
really feel strongly one way or the other. And
they just want to keep voting for people like,
I don't know, Lindsey Graham. And then they
stay. And you could have a Republican Party split
three ways. It I have no interest in giving
advice to these folks about what they should do.
I simply recognize the mathematical realities that
even if Trump splits off and takes 15 percent of
the party and these principled conservatives split
off and take 10 or 15 percent of the party, that
creates a situation in which Republicans, as
we know them or in any of these new iterations,
don't win for a decade. And if there would ever
be an opportunity for the left to make progress
in the United States, it would be that now,
unfortunately, the Democratic Party has shown
itself so often to be so incompetent that it
would probably still end up being a challenge
for a Democratic Party. Given the gift of a
Republican Party divided three ways, it would
probably still end up being an uphill battle for
the modern Democratic Party to make progress. But
at least they'd have the opportunity. We'll
follow it. Very, very interesting stuff.